not face the nation interview the
president said repeatedly that Obamacare
is dead but Republicans in Congress
haven't agreed on a replacement the
president told thousands of supporters
in Harrisburg Pennsylvania that he will
keep that promise and many others major
Garrett is outside the west wing of the
White House major good morning good
morning whatever President Trump says
and it varies from time to time the
hundred-day marker matters to him last
week he had his White House team
frantically pushing Obamacare repeal and
tax reform in this morning the
president's reelection campaign there is
one of those as a new TV ad touting 100
days of accomplishments I'll tell you
who doesn't cover pre-existing
conditions Obamacare you know why it's
dead
with his own health care bill on
legislative life support president Trump
pronounced President Obama's signature
law deceased but said one of that law's
key benefits would be included in his
own health care overhaul pre-existing
conditions are in the bill and I mandate
it I said has to be the latest House
version of the bill to repeal Obamacare
does not guarantee coverage for
pre-existing conditions it specifically
allows States to opt out of that mandate
mr. Trump suggested another redrafting
may be coming this is evolved over a
period of three or four weeks now we
really have a good bill I think they
could have voted on Friday I said just
relax don't worry about this phony
100-day footing the president spent his
hundredth day in office at a rally in
Pennsylvania and as his custom teed off
on the media they are gathered together
for the White House Correspondents
Dinner without the president
presidents traditionally attend the
annual function and tolerate a bit of
roasting but mr. Trump declined I think
is in Pennsylvania because he can't take
a joke there is no place I'd rather be
than right here in Pennsylvania to
celebrate supporters in the packed arena
were not concerned about the president's
few accomplishments in his first 100
days he stands up for what he believes
and follows through I mean it's only a
hundred days I am rome wasn't built in a
day the president also said another IRS
audit on his latest tax returns will
force those to be kept under lock and
key Charlie some congressional Democrats
have said they will block all attempts
to achieve tax reform until those tax
returns are publicly released thanks
major